hola bienvenidos a la entrevista de
france 24 en español nos acompaña en
esta oportunidad christina villarreal
velásquez recientemente fue incluida en
la lista de las 100 personalidades más
influyentes de 2022 por la revista
'time' el motivo escogido por esta
publicación estadounidense es su
compromiso y su liderazgo en la
despenalización del aborto en colombia
cristina es psicóloga y una de las
pioneras de causa justa por el aborto
estamos hablando de un movimiento
conformado por más de 100 organizaciones
y cerca de 130 activistas que lograron
que la corte constitucional colombiana
despenalizar a la interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo hasta la semana
24 de gestación y no fue la única
colombiana en integrar está lista porque
la acompaña su compañera de activismo
anna cristina gonzález vélez cristina
villarreal muchísimas gracias por su
presencia en la travista de france 24
muchas gracias santiago ustedes por su
interés en este tema gracias a ustedes
nuevamente usted ha dedicado gran parte
de su vida a defender los derechos de
las mujeres para decidir sobre sus
propios cuerpos que representa este
conocimiento para usted
así es yo tengo más de 30 años
trabajando en este tema de la
interrupción del embarazo yo empecé
trabajando en la prestación de los
servicios
hace muchos años cuando todavía la ley
en colombia prohibía totalmente el
aborto entonces en esa época lo que
hacíamos era atender mujeres que ya
llegaban con un aborto iniciado
prestándoles un servicio de significado
humanizado centrado en sus necesidades
el reconocimiento pues es un inmenso
honor
estar en esta lista
y yo recibo el reconocimiento en nombre
de las miles de mujeres que han tenido
que sufrir enfermar y morir por cuenta
de abortos mal practicados en este mundo
y especialmente en colombia christina la
activista irlandesa al baas smith
escribió en la publicación the time que
tanto ustedes no como 'ana cristina'
gonzález para legalizar el aborto en
colombia fueron directo al lugar que era
el obstáculo no en referencia a la corte
constitucional porque fueron a la
justicia y no al congreso
pues en colombia desde el año 79
se han intentado en varias muchas
ocasiones
a presentar iniciativas ante el
legislativo y ninguna de ellas ha
prosperado es decir que llevamos
prácticamente más de 40 años con esa
intención pero no lo nunca lo logramos
la primera vez que en colombia se
despenalizó parcialmente el aborto
cuando en el año 2006 la corte
constitucional también
aceptó tres causales para la
despenalización pues nos dimos cuenta
que esa era una opción que las corts
desafortunadamente en colombia el
congreso no es un congreso que haya
respetado los derechos individuales y en
temas como el aborto en el en temas como
la orientación sexual en temas como la
eutanasia
siempre ha sido la corte constitucional
la que nos ha mostrado un respeto mayor
por los derechos de las mujeres y por
eso resolvimos desde el movimiento causa
justa que por ahí habría que intentarlo
y por fortuna lo logramos en la
publicación de tan smith también destacó
la voy a citar no que para lograr la
despenalización a pesar de la influencia
de la derecha religiosa del país
tuvieron que pensar estratégicamente y
lo hicieron desde un comienzo o no como
se logró colocar la discusión sobre el
aborto en la agenda de discusión en un
país tan conservador como colombia
primero fundamental lo que muchas
denominan la despenalización social
verdad
de acuerdo eso es todavía una tarea
pendiente de la despenalización social
completa es una tarea pendiente y este
es uno de los retos que nos quedan
colombia efectivamente es un país
conservador pero es un país que como
digo tiene unas cortes y una corte
constitucional en particular muy liberal
en estos temas por fortuna
y digamos que las estrategias nosotros
lo que resolvimos fue después de que en
el 2006 se despenalizó el aborto en
estas tres causales desde la
organización y el colectivo que nosotros
representamos que es la mesa por la vida
la salud de las mujeres donde se gestó
la idea del movimiento a causa ajuste
por eso las dos somos las pioneras en
ese lugar nosotros empezamos a trabajar
desde el mismísimo día de del tren 10 de
mayo de 2006 por la implementación en
colombia' de esas tres causales y lograr
que eso se fuera se volviera una
realidad sin embargo durante los 16 años
que pasaron empezamos a ver claramente
que todo el tiempo las mujeres se
enfrentaban barreras en el sistema de
salud para poder tener acceso
real y concreto a los servicios
entonces como decimos nosotros nosotros
durante 16 años le apostamos realmente y
de manera comprometida y leal
a esa opción de la despenalización
parcial pero rap pero no nos dimos
cuenta de que no era suficiente de que
las mujeres seguían siendo
criminalizadas por abortos y por lo
tanto
volvimos a nuestra misión inicial que
desde la mesa por la vida la salud de
las mujeres nos habíamos propuesto desde
que la fundamos en el año 98 que era
lograr esta despenalización total
entonces
construimos más de 90 argumentos que
conversamos con muchos actores en el
país desde medios de comunicación y
opinadores políticos
personas del congreso que eran amigables
a esta causa con las mujeres logramos
también convocar un movimiento de
mujeres jóvenes que se tomaron las
calles y eso también contribuyó de
manera muy decisiva a que la corte que
hemos hubiera tomado la decisión que
tomó un enorme trabajo christina y desde
las bases hablemos ahora de un tema que
también es mencionado en la publicación
the time hablemos del momento que
atraviesa eeuu no con la corte suprema
que pretende revertir el derecho al
aborto no que sería una decisión
histórica no hoy estamos viendo a lo
largo de estos días símbolos de la lucha
pro aborto por la despenalización de la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo que
son sudamericanos y que llegaron hasta
eeuu verdad y menos para los verdes en
el puente de brooklyn en las estatuas de
la libertad incluso en las afueras del
congreso que siente usted cuando ve la
marea verde en el norte del continente y
es clave de verdad esa articulación
entre los movimientos de mujeres de todo
el mundo
de acuerdo pues nosotros en colombia
durante muchos años estuvimos inspiradas
en nuestra historia en lo que había sido
los logros de los eeuu con la decisión
de la corte suprema de brokers wey y fue
nuestro fue nuestra fuente de
inspiración por muchos años ver ahora
que esa esa decisión está peligrando
como está peligrando pues es es muy
sorprendente sin embargo también
entendemos que fueron muchos años de
estos movimientos anti derechos que se
han ido posicionando y quizás un poco de
y confianza que tuvo el movimiento pro
despenalización en el país de que esto
no podría suceder y debe estamos viendo
de esta situación tan difícil como lo
dice la revista 'time' en la publicación
para nosotros es también un honor porque
nuestra lucha puede ser una fuente de
inspiración para otros países países que
nunca han tenido una despenalización ni
parcial ni total ni nada parecido y
ahora que estamos teniendo esta suerte
como de solidaridad internacional de la
que habla la publicación y que se ve en
ejemplos como los que usted acaba de
mencionar en los eeuu pues digamos es
una fuente de preocupación saber que eso
está pasando pero también de alegría de
saber que este es un movimiento muy
fuerte que está atravesando todo el
continente y eso nos da
y más ganas de seguir luchando y de
seguir logrando cosas no solamente para
colombia sino para otros países
christina volvemos para colombia
nuevamente el país está a las puertas de
una segunda vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales y el debate sobre
feminismos se metió de lleno en la
carrera electoral estamos hablando ahora
de los candidatos gustavo petro y
rodolfo hernández que llegan a este
ballottage con visiones a priori
totalmente antagónicas verdad este
último ha tenido de hecho frases con una
gran carga de misoginia tienen ustedes
retrocesos quizás en derechos
conquistados
pues digamos que yo siempre digo que la
batalla por la despenalización del
aborto es una batalla que nunca se gana
del todo y hay muchos ejemplos en el
mundo del de eeuu pues es el más
reciente pero pero muchas veces en el
mundo
desafortunadamente cosas que se logran
se dan paso adelante y luego se
retrocede uno o dos pasos entonces más
que temamos nuestros sesos y no creemos
que se vayan a dar retrocesos pronto
sabemos que nuestro reto está en vigilar
muy fuertemente lo logrado en protegerlo
de muchas maneras entre ellas a través
de la despenalización social de la que
hablábamos al comienzo
christina nos queda poco tiempo pero no
quiero dejar de realizar la siguiente
pregunta usted hizo referencia segundo
momentos a la importancia de la
movilización social es verdad esto es
clave en cualquier proceso de
despenalización del aborto ha quedado
demostrado en todos los países donde se
logró ahora como fue lograr esto en un
país como colombia que quizás a
diferencia de otros de la región no
tiene una trayectoria
tan fuerte no de movilizaciones
pues eso fue muy emocionante y para mí
personalmente
sorpresivo yo como usted muy claramente
lo menciona veía en el pasado como en
otros países argentina y chile- diría
que los ejemplos más fuertes
nos mostraban unas calles llenas de
mujeres
reclamando y exigiendo por sus derechos
y eso no sucedía en colombia de todas
maneras esto se da también en el marco
de un país que el año en el año
tuvo muchísimas movilizaciones no
solamente en este campo sino en muchos
otros campos por toda la situación
social y política que está viviendo este
país y digamos que a
en ese en ese ámbito y en ese entorno
surge entonces la movilización social
también de la marea verde en colombia'
cosa que nos emociona mucho y repito que
creo que ahí estuvo muy buena parte del
éxito también y por eso a esa
movilización social de esas mujeres
jóvenes y al movimiento de mujeres en
general le debemos este reconocimiento
también cristina villarreal muchísimas
gracias por este tiempo en france 24 en
español ha sido un placer dialogar con
usted gracias a santiago gracias a
ustedes un además ya nuestra audiencia
como siempre le invitamos a que sigan
informándose en el resto de nuestra
programación y también por supuesto en
france24 punto com sigan junto a
nosotros
[Música]